[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bon soir à ceux qui nous
rejoignent pour le second débat de la
soirée consacrée aux élections
départementales et cette fois ci c'est
gros plan sur le territoire de belfort à
un débat de 52 minutes qui va vous
permettre de comprendre les enjeux de
ces départements et les projets des uns
et des autres ce département de 140
mille habitants est découpé en neuf
cantons chaque canton élira un bino a
nommé une femme et les 18 conseillers
départementaux éliront à leur tour un
président ou une présidente
actuellement c'est la droite qui est
majoritaire dans un territoire de
belfort et c'est florian bouquet des
républicains qui en est le président
depuis 2000 15 2015 c'est le dernier
scrutin départemental et le département
a basculé de gauche à droite
il bénéficie d'une petite majorité dix
conseillers départementaux tous aient
l'air sauf un un ou des i qui ne se
représente pas l'opposition est scindée
en deux groupes six conseillers de
gauche avait deux grs donc de la gauche
républicaine est socialiste et 4 divers
gauche auxquels il faut ajouter
également deux élus adhérents du modem
je vous présente les donc les quatre
invités qui vont débattre devant vous
sur le territoire de belfort tout
d'abord florian bouquet le président des
républicains du conseil départemental du
territoire de belfort
face à lui samia jaber divers gauche
elle est conseillère d'opposition il
représente ici non seulement les quatre
divers gauche de l'assemblée
départementale
mais aussi les deux élus grs christophe
soustelle lui et du rassemblement
national
il est également tête de liste pour le
territoire de belfort pour le
département pour les élections
régionales
et puis pour finir jean christophe mais
sein du modem conseiller départemental
sortant d'opposition le modem c'est
l'une des composantes de la majorité
présidentielle des manuels macron alors
premier tour de table madame messieurs
avec une question simple pourquoi est-ce
que vous êtes candidat
l'ordre a été tiré au sort juste avant
l'émission et c'est florian bouquet qui
s'y colle en premier on vous écoute
pourquoi de mort vous vous représentez
m'a tout d'abord parce que j'ai un
immense plaisir depuis 2015 à travailler
au service des dents sont le des tarifs
fortin à l'afp
aussi pour les et les élus municipaux
les associations locales et j'ai eu
vraiment le temps dans le champ du
handicap avec le territoire 100% clusif
j'ai signé la première convention avec
le groupe orange pour le déploiement du
très haut débit et fort de ce bilan
eh bien je souhaite bien sûr le
poursuivre et l'amplifier monsieur
soustelle pour le rassemblement national
pourquoi votre candidature mais parce
que moi je m'inscris dans l'enracinement
du rassemblement national c'est vrai que
le territoire de belfort se situe entre
deux grandes régions où notre parti fait
deux grands scores l'alsace et la
franche-comté et nous espérons bien que
leurs semblables rassemblements
nationale tire son épingle du jeu au
cours de cette élection
jean christophe messang vous pour le
modem pourquoi vous présentez-vous à
nouveau je signale juste que vous avez
remplacé christophe grudler en cours de
mandat parce que monsieur gruyère a été
élue au parlement européen en 2019 plein
ce pour les gens pour les habitants du
territoire de belfort qui méritent
davantage de considération et de projets
constructifs pour leur avenir
aujourd'hui pour eux le compte n'y est
pas donc c'est pour cela qu'il faut se
mobiliser sur les cantons avec nos
candidats pour de la représentation nous
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
le modem donc vous vous faites partie
samia jaber vous vous êtes élue
conseillère départementale sortante
pourquoi vous représentez vous ce qui
est important en fait c'est de changer
la vie de nos concitoyens et le conseil
départemental est en première ligne sur
l'accompagnement des familles de la
naissance jusqu'à la fin de vie donc je
pense que nous avons énormément de
choses à apporter à nos concitoyens
alors je représente ici l'ensemble de la
gauche puisque nous avons fait le choix
de partir rassemblés à cette élection il
y avait une attente forte
donc nous avons pris nos responsabilités
et on souhaite évidemment proposer autre
chose que ce que nous venons de vivre
pendant six ans une majorité qui n'a
fait que de la petite gestion qui n'a
pas préparé l'avenir et je pense que le
département aujourd'hui non seulement
besoin de nouvelles politiques mais
aussi d'élus
en capacité de mener des politiques plus
ambitieuse en termes d'attractivité
mais également en termes
d'accompagnement parce que la crise
sociale a montré la crise sanitaire a
montré les failles de notre système je
pense que nous devons ici apporter de
nouvelles réponses vous allez être la
plus bavarde sur ce plateau je sors ce
soir
donc faut faire attention au temps joue
je vous mets juste en garde les uns et
les autres à leur première question
premier thème que nous avons choisi
d'aborder ces l implantation d'amazon
alors la compétence économique ne fait
pas partie des compétences d'un
département souhaite mais ce dossier a
suscité d'énormes polémique sur le
département et je pense que les
habitants du territoire ont envie de
savoir ce que vous comment vous voyez
les uns et les autres ce dossier alors
je résume amazon géant américain du
commerce en ligne s'installe à fontaine
une commune de l'agglomération du grand
belfort une première plate forme donc
est prévue elle en travaux elle devrait
embaucher 450 personnes dès le mois
d'octobre
et puis une deuxième est en projet elle
est actuellement bloqué par des recours
en justice et l'a donc 76 mille mètres
carrés pour un millier d'emplois en
décembre 2022
florian bouquet pourquoi avoir accepté
ou même peut-être provoqué la venue
d'amazon sur votre territoire
mais tout d'abord c'est un gros
employeur ou l'avait rappelé
et c'est une formidable chance pour pour
le territoire de belfort
il faut savoir que pendant 15 ans il ne
s'est rien passé sur la zone d'activités
économiques de l'aéroparc et depuis que
le grand belfort a récupéré la
compétence du développement économique
legrand belfort avec la soneb encore las
le deps et la société d'équipement du
département selon vous êtes président
également deux ferries absolument
et donc nous avons travaillé à
l'implantation de nouvelles entreprises
emma amazon en fait partie alors c'est
une formidable opportunité pour de
nombreux bénéficiaires du rsa en nombre
près de 4500
et donc moi je vois bien lorsque le
conseil départemental a créé une adresse
spécifique pour l'emploi sur la zone
l'aéroparc à ce jour nous totalisons 327
dépôt de candidature sur le site de
conduire selon le premier argument c'est
l'emploi seul emploi bien évidemment
parce que vous l'avez compris il faut
aussi créer de l'emploi pour stabiliser
de la population dans notre département
on a bien compris aussi que des grosses
locomotives comme alstom ou general
electric n'était plus aussi pourvoyeur
d'emplois que précédemment
et donc il était nécessaire de
travailler à l'installation de nouvelles
entreprises et amazon avec les deux
unités
vous avez évoqué la première de celles
de livraison derniers kilomètres le gros
la grosse unité de 76 mille mètres
carrés il ya d'autres implantations
encore sur sur le secteur on a ici on a
on va déjà parlé d' amazon on va faire
un premier tour de table pour savoir ce
que vous pensez
les uns et les autres de ce projet samia
jaber ne sommes pas contre l'emploi mais
nous nous préférons défendre l'emploi de
general electric que l'implantation
d'amazon alors sur un oiseau vous
demandez où c'est incompatible
on peut pas faire les deux en même temps
c'est un problème de priorités nous
considérons que sur general electric
monsieur bouquet monsieur mais ce ne
sont pas assez battu et n'ont pas joué
leur rôle juste respondents en parler
après répond sur amazon uniquement ce
que nous avons dénoncé ces de déni de
démocratie aux lors du débat des
municipales j'ai ici même dit un
monsieur meslot qu'il fallait qu'ils
disent aux belfortains que c'était
amazon qui s'installait il a été dans le
refus et on a fait en sorte de cacher
aux belfortains
nous nous considérons que c'est un sujet
il peut y avoir un débat nous avons
demandé à monsieur bouquet des études
d'impact parce que ce n'est pas rien un
certain nombre de plateformes sur le
secteur et d'autre part nous avons
demandé à monsieur bouquet d'organiser
un référendum
quand est ce que la vie de nos
concitoyens va être demandée sur ce
dossier les deux nous ont été refusés
donc nous nous avons dénoncé d'abord le
déni de démocratie
et puis en tous les cas ce que je
souhaite dire mot sur amazon c'est que
nous au pouvoir nous traiterons le
dossier différemment nous lancerons les
études d'impact et nous remettrons le
citoyen au coeur des politiques locales
et de la décision oui mais si vous
imaginez vous êtes présidente vous
pouvez pas
empêcher la venue d'amazon c'est pas
possible si les charges en effet si les
choses sont bouclés non mais il ya des
études d'impact qui doivent être faites
aujourd'hui on n'a pas du tout pensé à
l'impact écologique et économique de
cette implantation monsieur soustelle
pour le rassemblement national quelle
est votre vision de ce dossier donc je
vais pas être aussi disert que mais oui
mais si mais si vous avez le même temps
de la rolls de vous inquiéter d'accord
ok mais je
mais bon sur un maillot oui sur amazon
on est bien d'accord sur amazon donc
nous nous sommes il faut que faisant pas
partie de la de la mandature sortante
donc nous n'avons pas été conviés à
l'analyse du dossier donc nous voyons ça
un peu de loin malheureusement donc on
va voir simplement une des notions de
principe
moi je dois dire qu'il faut justement
vous vous plaignez détruit 1 du dossier
un référendum proposé par la gauche
ça vous dit ou pas mais pourquoi pas
nous on pourrait très bien il ya comme
ça des choses on va pas se refuser qu'on
me dire ce genre de choses je pense
qu'effectivement quand on vit dans un
dans un département un territoire un
beau département comme le territoire de
belfort
effectivement on est là pour y
travailler mais on est là pour y vivre
et y vivre ça veut dire c'est prendre en
compte aussi les aspirations de des gens
qui vivent autour donc il faut aussi
prendre en compte leur leur désaccord
nous sommes pas contre l'emploi
évidemment ma amazon a des qualités mais
il peut aussi avoir des défauts et tout
ça il faut correctement les vidéos c'est
d'après ce que j'ai compris du dossier
c'est quand même d en bas on va voir
donc c'est une plateforme dans lequel il
va y avoir des camions qui vont ou les
cd dire c'est un mode de fonctionnement
de 2 pour les travailleurs prêts pour
les salariés qui vont être un sujet qui
lui a dit parler comme l'extrême gauche
parce que c'est un petit peu la
déformation dire syndical je suis désolé
mais mais voilà par des salariés
effectivement il ya des choses qui on ne
peut pas forcément accepter tout et
n'importe quoi et on dit que un emploi
créé chez amazon ces deux emplois
supprimés dans le commerce local feu oui
vous pensez que vous alliez me je
donnais ça mais comme je n'ai pas étudié
la chose donc je ne
pas avancer des arguments récit voilà on
va demander à monsieur messin amazon
pour ou contre
la réponse est plutôt de l'ordre de la
réflexion que pour ou contre et la
réflexion en tant que conseil
départemental sortant il n'y en a pas eu
et monsieur bouquet affecte donc
cavalier seul il a même infantiliser la
commission départementale et ça a choqué
tout le monde on est tous deux d'un
commun accord pour ce constat alors
amazon c'est extrêmement difficile on a
tous compris que ce silence était un
deal qui avait été passé avec le conseil
départemental
on a tous compris que amazon
ce sont ce sont des emplois qui sont
étendues sur une large terrain foncier
et le rapport emploi et et occupations
au sol est très mauvais ça on l'a
compris on a compris que bien sûr que
vaut mieux avoir amazon dans notre giron
dans le bain d'autres départements qu'à
20 km nous sommes d'accord mais ce qui
est regrettable c'est que vraiment pas
eu de réflexion et c'est à l'image de ce
fonctionnement départementale où il n'y
a jamais eu de commission de travail
moi j'aurais pu pointer des des choses
extrêmement simple sur le l'implantation
de l'économie ce qu'il faut c'est avant
tout penser aussi aux autres ou principe
d'équité
si vous donnez un million amazon il faut
aussi penser à tous les commerçants aux
artisans il faut aussi redistribuer à
droite ce que vous donnez à gauche
donc est ce que vous craignez aussi
c'est que les terrains là qui sont
utilisés par amazon ne pourront pas être
utilisées par d'autres entreprises
c'est ça aussi que vous craignez c'est
une évidence et c'est dans la réflexion
démocratique sont querelles de clochers
qu'on peut arriver à
d évidence si demain un employeur un
industriel veut s'implanter sur les
départements on ne l'aura pas fait le
tapis rouge on aura plus de 10 de foncia
c'est en foncier en tout cas nous
n'aurons pas anticipé et notre
attractivité aurait été mauvaise
on va faire répondre florian bouquet et
du mensonge aussi sur le nombre
écoutez moi je voudrais surtout répondre
parce qu'il ya comme alors déjà ce qui a
été dit c est ce que c'était une clause
avec amazon du fait que vous vous tézier
les uns et les autres
je pense aussi à damien meslot doc maire
et président du grand belfort qui n'a
pas révélé que c'était amazon est ce
qu'il y avait une clause un deal à 10min
non il n'y a pas de deal je tiens à vous
rassurer sur une question nous on a
traité avec deux gros opérateurs
immobiliers qui sont vailog effectuera
pour ces deux opérations après chargea à
ses opérateurs de louer ça aurait pu
être aujourd'hui ces amazones sont que
deux salons d'automne une bien autre ou
d'autres marques
simplement les études sont fournis à
sont jointes dans les dents les dépôts
de permis de construire elles sont ils
sont tout à fait consultables avec les
trafics avec les études comme vous dites
et des études environnementales dalmat
rend tout est absolument joints et un
excédent le permis de construire il est
consultable à la mairie de foussemagne
de deux fontaines ya aucun souci
là-dessus
et puis simplement je vois bien on dit
qu'il ya pas eu débat mais quand madame
jaber évoque le sujet au conseil
communautaire dont je suis membre
également la motion qui a été présentée
par votre groupe a recueilli 11 % c'est
donc qu'il y a eu un débat il a été même
long le sujet a été largement partie
vous avez au conseil par le cas des
élections municipales aux élections
municipales vous avez fait votre plus
mauvais score de toute votre carrière
politique donc vraiment moi je veux dire
par là comme je vois l'engouement des
belfortains à rechercher un emploi
quand je voit l'arrivée d'un d'un grand
groupe du monde et d'une belle signature
de
belfort eh bien je me dis que l'union
entre le grand belfort l'assaut des
bébés aussi le conseil départemental et
au dos bien ça produit aussi de bons
effets dont le mythique et je tiens à
rassurer aussi vos auditeurs
il n'y a pas eu un million versé par le
conseil départemental contrairement à ce
que dit monsieur messin téléspectateurs
chez nous sont des téléspectateurs donc
ce que vous dites concertation il y a eu
il n'y avait pas dit là avec amazon etc
est ce que vous comprenez quand même que
des certains habitants et des
associations qui protègent
l'environnement se soit mobilisée et un
peu agité le un petit drapeau en disant
attention pour mériter celle enseigne
que certains idéologues essaie
d'attaquer c'est pas ça aurait été une
autre enseigne il n'y aurait pas eu de
soucis au niveau mais rhône mental
c'était ça la même construction en plus
ils sont très vertueux il ya les
panneaux solaires tout partout je veux
dire à ce niveau là il ya simplement
l'enseigne qui est un symbole de la de
la grande distribution de la vente à
distance
lavande à 10 ans et est un groupe
américain c'est un groupe américain de
la rentrée ans ce 5 % des transactions
sur internet
en parlant de grands groupes américains
on va passer au deuxième sujet
économique à savoir general electric
alors je vais résumer aussi pour que
tout le monde est à peu près des mêmes
informations départ c'est un gros
dossier sur sur belfort en 2014 guy
general electric rachète alstom et
promet de créer 1000 emplois déjà et
d'en faire un pôle d'excellence mondial
résultat sept ans plus tard des
centaines d'emplois ont été détruits des
savoir-faire sont partis à l'étranger
notamment en inde et en chine et general
electric a préféré payer 50 millions
d'euros d'amendé soit 50000 euros par
emploi détruit plutôt que de donc
assumer ses promesses alors monsieur
soustelle vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure travailleurs et vous nous avez
dit que vous étiez syndicaliste en effet
vous êtes rassemblement national mais
aussi syndicaliste fo cgt c'est donc
chez general electric
que faire et surtout est ce que le
département est ce que les élus du
territoire ont fait suffisamment
je pense que non je pense qu'il aurait
fallu
comment dire être encore plus fort j'en
veux pour preuve je dirais quand on
regarde comment ça s'est déroulé vous
voyez toute cette mobilisation qu'on a
connu dès 2009 2019 pardon quand on a
appris le plan social c'est vrai que les
représentants du personnel ont été reçus
par les plus hautes autorités par le
président puis mais je veux dire au
niveau du sénat de l'assemblée nationale
et cetera il y avait beaucoup de
promesses et je pense au temps du côté
de la gauche que que du côté de la
droite ait l'air je pense par exemple à
gérard larcher président du sénat
résidence villers exactement et qu'est
ce qui s'est passé rien aujourd'hui
pendant que vous avez des problèmes
alors concrètement qu'est ce que
j'aurais dû faire florian bouquet
président les républicains en du
déploiement du territoire face à un
groupe américain comme général vous avez
des salariés aujourd'hui qui se battent
avec leurs moyens ce sont nos moyens
juridiques
aujourd'hui les salariés on dirait on me
en justice le groupe pour non respect de
l'accord alors vous avez parlé de 2014
et 2015 plutôt un voilà et puis aussi de
2019 je pense que par exemple les le
département aurait pu donner vous voyez
des ressources mettre à disposition des
ressources juridiques pour essayer d un
parce que je peux vous dire qu'un
intérêt appuyé les salariés sont les
aider pour eux essayer de voir que lui
pas en justice en général et la corde
mais si vous savez en interne nous avons
des représentants des salariés qui font
le maximum qui rampe qui rend compte
effectivement autant les élus locaux que
nationaux
mais voilà ils se battent avec leurs
propres moyens sans avocat ils se
sentent un peu seuls
alors il ya des bons et on va dire
intentions mais je pense que derrière ça
je peux comprendre parce que ce soit
donc l air ou bien le parti socialiste
on va dire la gauche
je veux dire ils veulent pas froisser
emmanuel macron qui à la base de tout ça
vous savez on a le rapport marc l'ex
vous connaissez marc l'ex ce député qui
a fait un excellent travail qui montre
que en fait beaucoup de gens qui ont
bénéficié du cogneur de 7,2 cette vente
de d'alstom de hunter 21h électrique
ils ont été aussi des donateurs de la
campagne électorale de mme emmanuel
macron et ça je veux dire quand on a des
partis comme ça le parti socialiste on
va dire et ses responsables de vos
propos oui je suis d'accord absolument
message et assume
jean-christophe messin que faire face à
general electric qui ne remplit pas ses
engagements
quand on est au département alors moi je
serai toujours gêné de parler de general
electric je pense que je suis très
respectueux des idées des travailleurs
de giron de general electric qui
connaissent très bien la situation faut
simplement rappeler que c'est un piège
américain avant tout si on met ces lois
quand même extra territorial est ainsi
aussi qu'après l'attitude de patrick
kron directeur de johnston qui a fait
qu'on est arrivé à cette situation là et
je rappellerai quand qu'en 2015 tous les
élus de locaux entre le deal siemens ou
de jijé dans l'électrique ils étaient
tous pour dilater tous pour 10 et ça
peut s'entendre et c'était assez logique
maintenant que ce contrat ne soit pas
honorer et qu'on arrive dans cette
situation là c'était aussi entendable
c'était dans le deal que voilà et puis
on sait que c'est pas des oeuvres de
charité les américains donc on est dans
une situation difficile et l'état la
majorité présidentielle fait un pas
énorme pour conserver les emplois
notamment deux mille emplois ont repris
par edf pour pour general electric
et en plus dans mon canton donc ça c'est
jeu j'y tiens beaucoup
je suis là faire aussi avec la ministre
déléguée panier rue gachet
donc je suis prêt mais je veux pas
parler à la place des employés je pense
qu'il faut être respectueux et les
politiques devraient être très modeste
et j'invite tout le monde à regarder ce
col l'alstom scandale d'état
samia jaber vous en dites quoi de
l'allusion du département par rapport à
juin je suis un petit peu en en
opposition par rapport aux trois
interventions
je pense qu'au contraire les élus
peuvent et doivent faire sur ce dossier
je suis assez amer parce que monsieur
bouquet monsieur mes sauts n'ont pas
fait ce qu'il devait faire
alors ça ne suffit pas d'écrire au
ministre ça ne suffit pas d'appeler les
belfortains à la manifestation
l'état est comptable des engagements qui
ont été pris par general electric
les temps étaient autour de la table et
dès 2019
j'ai demandé à monsieur bouquet et à
monsieur meslot de faire le rapport de
force avec l'état
nous ne pouvons pas en effet mettre en
justice general electric par contre nous
pouvons mettre en place un rapport de
force avec l'état et nous pouvons
appeler l'état à sa responsabilité par
rapport à un territoire et des emplois
que nous devons défendre et dès le
départ j'avais dit il faut absolument
accompagné l'intersyndicale dans la
plate qu'elle allait déposer notamment
auprès de l'état qui ne faisait pas ce
qu'ils devaient faire je vous le
rappelle que stéphane le foll au moment
de la signature du rachat a dit l'état
et comptables et nous suivrons le
respect des engagements
rien n'a été fait par le gouvernement
macron mais ce que je constate c'est que
localement nos élus on dans un premier
temps accompagné general electric dans
leur communication officielle et ça nous
l'avons regretté et dénoncé à plusieurs
reprises et d'autre part ont laissé les
choses se passaient en spectateur et je
crois que là ça a été un des éléments
les plus négatifs du bilan de monsieur
bouquet est le monsieur mais cela alors
vous associez toujours damien meslot je
rappelle qui est donc maire de la ville
de belfort et président du grand belfort
de la communauté d'agglomération damien
meslot qui auparavant était député du
territoire et qui est bien sûr les
républicains une minute pour répondre
florian bouquet sur sur general electric
et puis surtout ce que je voudrais vous
dire quand même selon les derniers
chiffres officiels du chômage au
quatrième trimestre 2000 20
donc donc il ya six mois votre
département est le plus touché par le
chômage en bourgogne franche comté
je pense que ce chiffre je ne vous
l'apprends pas 8,6 pour cent de la
population active est sans emploi chez
vous vous vous sentez un peu ou beaucoup
responsable
ben on se sent toujours responsable bien
sûr parce que depuis 2010 est on avait
une décrue importante du nombre de
bénéficiaires du rsa dans notre
département
c'était lié aussi à l'activité
économique à l'action dynamique menée
aussi par les élus de la majorité
départementale et à l'efficacité de nos
dispositifs d'insertion et bien c'est
vrai que l'aide après la crise que vides
nous a frappés durement à la frapper
durement aussi tous les intérimaires
mais tout le monde a été tracé qui ont
été mais plus encore le temps le
territoire de belfort où là où
l'industrie est très de l'industrie de
production est très fortement présente
et je le vois au niveau du conseil
départemental on a pris 10 3 % de
bénéficiaires du rsa en plus donc ça se
traduit par une augmentation importante
aussi des allocations mais sur general
electric vous auriez pu faire ce pas le
fut mieux parce que sur general electric
bien sûr il y à l'annonce de ce plan
social qui n'encourt pas produit tous
ses effets il y a eu le fait de ne pas
créer les emplois qui étaient attendues
au moment du rachat
ça c'était en 2015 mais j'en veux
surtout au président de la république
qui est venu dans les ateliers de
belfort qui est venu réaffirmer la
solidité de ce partenariat de ce rachat
et qui aujourd'hui ne prononce jamais le
mot general electric il était ministre
d'économie à l'époque aujourd'hui le
président de la république il a un poids
important pour négocier avec les
américains seront conseillés aux
affaires économiques qui était une belle
et à bercy est devenu aujourd'hui le pdg
de general electric donc la connexion
est très forte entre les deux hommes
et quelles solutions ils n'apportent
c'est ça et le fait avec le prix est
muet sur la question
vous avez compris que il se refile le
bébé là à wimille jean-claude mais ça je
fais il faut rappeler que c'est quand
même le marché aussi qui fait que
on vend du matériel sinon les turbines à
charbon nous sommes d'accord n'ont plus
d'avenir des turbines pour le nucléaire
pour l'hydrogène d'accord mais c'est
quand même la loi du marché qui est
qu'il y des affaires et quand
layton se met avec general electric
s'est aussi pour essayer de conquérir le
marché asiatique
or on a pas fait d affaires qu on
voulait alors mail par mois je demande
un moratoire sur la mise en oeuvre de ce
plan social
parce qu'il ya des négociations qui sont
ouvertes avec edf avec un consortium
autour d'edf
et puis de deux géants mais s'il tenue
du nucléaire des deux mais il est
important qu'on laisse le temps au
groupe pour mener à terme ces
négociations et ne pas produire les
effets négatifs de ce plan social
monsieur soustelle or vous avez la
parole quelques secondes d'accord notre
c'est pour dire je je vais pas rentrer
dans les négociations actuelles je
laisse faire le gouvernement ils
essaient de sauver les meubles en plus
en prévision des commentaires des
élections présidentielles seront on le
voit on voit arriver le nom mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que je voudrais voir
donc monsieur mes seins ou madame javert
savoir que monsieur macron monsieur
macron faisait partie du gouvernement de
monsieur hollande et on vous le
connaissez ce monsieur il n'est pas sûr
il a dénoncé à l'époque oui mais bon je
te rappeler que monsieur montebourg
c'est le jour contre monsieur m'accroche
je vous racontais justement les femmes
on va pas refaire le débat général
electric alstom siemens et c'est parce
qu'on m'a débordé dans les journaux de
demain matin donc je vous propose de
passer au sujet suivant à savoir le
social vous en avez dit deux mots quand
on vous parle d'économie ben vous
répondez le nombre de bénéficiaires du
rsa augmente vous avez dit 4500 si je me
trompe pas votre budget social ses 72
millions d'euros me soit 58 % du budget
des dépenses
on va peut-être parler tout de suite du
côté rsa
qu'est ce que vous faites concrètement
vous avez dit on a essayé de on était
arrivé avant le coup vide ou l'aco vide
à faire baisser le nombre de
bénéficiaires qu'est ce que vous avez
fait concrètement tout d'abord on s'est
aperçu que les principaux freins au
retour à l'emploi c'était la mobilité
bien évidemment et la garde d'enfants
alors sur la mobilité on a travaillé
avec une plateforme qui s'appelle moby
jobs qui permet de faciliter les
déplacements des salariés pour faciliter
le retour à l'emploi parce que très
souvent ils n'ont pas de voiture en état
il le nie le certif effet le contrôle
technique pour inoculer et puis ensuite
pour les jeunes femmes qui ont des
enfants
il y avait aussi la problématique est
donc à travers un partenariat que la
ville de belfort on a une crèche qui est
dédié à des bénéficiaires du rsa qui
veulent trouver des facilités de garde
pour se rendre à leur emploi on a aussi
replacer les entreprises au coeur du
dispositif à travers la labellisation
amplitude jeux récompensés entreprises
qui sont vertueuses en matière
d'insertion
on va faire un petit tour de table pour
savoir ce que vous pensez les uns et les
autres de cette action sociale vous
quand on vous dit asocial oui moi que je
dis action sociale c'est que
malheureusement donc le gouvernement une
fois de plus à modifier donc la manière
dont donc enlevé par un plat taxe
foncière lors si c'est bien pour les
particuliers mais effectivement ça rend
d'oeuvre des ressources mais je dirais
que notre côté il ya des dépenses qui
sont qui ont été et est donc déplacé
vers les départements je pense aux
mineurs aux mineurs non à quoi
isolé ce niveau est d'aider des migrants
clandestins qui qui vont être à cause je
dire on a ici une séquence avec le pacte
de marrakech qui va organiser encore
plus d'immigration dans nos pays at elle
est juste une question d'un moniteur de
belfort il ya combien de mineurs isolés
à dont un qui est à peu près 80 quelque
chose comme ça je
j'ai pas suivre mais c'est à peu près de
l'ordre de grandeur mais ce qui va se
passer c'est que en plus de le ministre
de la justice dupond moretti lui a signé
un arrêté dans lequel il va pouvoir
répartir
c'est très bien mais je voudrais
d'action sociale doit département du
territoire pour parler nationale
qu'est-ce que moi ce qu'on voulait faire
source
on est d'accord wigan taxe foncière pour
les gars c'est vrai que nous ce qu'on
veut c'est que on veut en voudraient si
on était aux affaires s'était proposé
d'abord des actions pour pour nos
pauvres je crois que c'est important et
je pense qu'il faut développer des
filières de local oui ça c'est important
donner la possibilité de trouver un
emploi donc on parlait d'amazon mais il
ya d'autres manières de faire donc
développé le localisme
on peut trouver par un peu donné assez
de localisme c'est des circuits coup
c'est sur exactement donc je pense que
ça le département peut proposer et peut
inciter à développer ce genre de
monsieur messin retour vous des actions
sociales vous vous répondez quoi je
réponds qu'on essaie de faire pour le
mieux sachant que les recettes diminuent
les dépenses augmentent c'est vraiment
un jeu d'équilibriste
difficile donc il reste peu de levier
le levier principal bien sûr c'est la
prospérité économique c'est par là qu'on
peut rétablir les choses mais il ya un
autre levier c'est bien sûr le team
isation de la dépense c'est d'essayer de
d'améliorer pour la proximité par
exemple il n'y a pas d' accueil
solidarité qui va disparaître sur
belfort
c'est peut-être dommage c'est peut-être
pas dans ceux dans ce schéma là qu'il
faut s'engager
et puis il y à aussi on peut peut-être
redéployer certains moyens
humain peut-être qu'il ya des gens qui
soient aussi un peu sous pression qui se
reconnaissent dans le travail social
c'est extrêmement difficile
et puis autrement je pense que
honnêtement il faut faire pour le mieux
que le comme ce bouquet a fait pas mal
mais je suis persuadé qu'on peut faire
beaucoup mieux samia jaber votre gare à
vous sur l'action sociale de vie y est
moins de bénéficiaires de rsa il faut de
l'emploi mais je pense que en la matière
on n'a pas investi à c'est pendant ces
six années sur notamment les projets
structurants qui permet justement le
soutien à l'économie locale
d'abord et plus globalement sur tout
l'action sociale j'ai vraiment le
sentiment qu'on est devenu une
collectivité de guichet social sans
accompagnement global et surtout sans
porter des projets d'avenir qui
justement permettent de travailler sur
notre attractivité et apporte évidemment
des solutions pérennes d'emplois et pour
sortir de là de la prise en charge
sociale
maintenant les mineurs isolés vous en
dites quoi
80 accueilli l'année dernière dans le
territoire de sur les mineurs isolés
donc belfort n'est pas seul dans cette
problématique c'est une collectivité
c'est les collectivités locales de
l'ensemble du pays et même l'europe et
puisque nous avons signé notre pays a
signé une convention européenne qui nous
oblige à protéger les mineurs quand ils
arrivent sur notre territoire
je pense qu'on le fait plutôt bien
jusqu'à maintenant bon il ya une
augmentation large et le sentiment que
ça ça se réduit mais il faut voir aussi
la vie de ces jeunes on en a rencontré
qui ont passé des périples assez
terrifiant et je pense que nous faisons
plutôt bien les choses
ce qui est important par contre c'est de
les insérer derrière et là par contre je
pense qu'il ya un vrai elle une réelle
possibilité de les insérer dans l'emploi
j'ai plusieurs exemples de jeunes
apprentis et qui aujourd'hui sont placés
aux noms au hasard les bots ou en
lecture d'été dans les prisons en larmes
dans le btp en action sociale dont quand
on vient de traverser la crise qu vide
est-ce qu'elle a été gérée correctement
dans le territoire de belfort par le
département on a eu un gros problème
avec le centre de vaccination
on a eu un débat au conseil
communautaire monsieur mécène présent
monsieur bouquet nous annonce que l'état
ne veut plus du centre de vaccination
géré par le département et nous fait
d'ailleurs voté naïvement on l'a cru une
motion qui condamne l état par rapport à
la hausse entre de vaccination et le
lendemain on a appris qu'en fait on
avait été complètement roulé dans la
farine
et là aussi c'est un fonctionnement qui
est pas du tout acceptable monsieur
bouquet voulait arrêter le centre de
vaccination nous nous proposions plutôt
d'aller jusqu'à l'automne est d'ailleurs
donnée dans notre programme nous
proposons de maintenir le centre de
vaccination jusqu'à l'automne pour aider
aussi à la vaccination plus générale
donc sur ce dossier là alors faire
répondre quoi les faire répondre autre
chose
les avait roulés dans la farine
donc le centre de tripoter patrol me
croirait si l'on va pas rentrer je vais
donc le centre de vaccination mobile ce
qui va continuer vous éveiller l'envié
janvier je fais partie des premiers des
parts présidents de départements à avoir
proposé les services de la collectivité
pour développer accélérer la vaccination
sans rentrer dans une guerre de
tranchées avec l'état sur les quantités
des centres de vaccination ils arrivent
à être torero part j'avais proposé dès
le début janvier à l'arrivée des
premiers vaccins j'avais proposé l'aide
du fossé départemental comme on avait
fait aussi pour la fabrication des
masques en à belfort
l'an passé eh bien on a lancé l'unité
mobile de vaccination et d'ailleurs je
note qu'on a été parmi les plus vertueux
on a été le département qui enregistre
le meilleur taux de vaccination de la
région bourgogne franche comté ce dont
je me réjouis
alors pour tout vous dire j'ai proposé
mes services ou alors au préfet qui a
adhéré à la proposition
et puis contre toute attente il y avait
une volonté de la part de l'état et de
la 2de montée en charge de faire de
monteux faire monter en charge de dudus
antre du phare mais en asséchant
descente comme giromagny et l'unité
mobile de vaccination et j'ai moi même
un mail qui nous être adressées au
conseil départemental qui nous
demandaient même les noms des personnes
et leur numéro de téléphone pour assurer
la deuxième vaccination donc on peut
formuler les choses comme on veut
moi j'ai ma conscience je sais ce que
j'affirme j'ai des écrits et donc je moi
je suis vraiment pas là pour faire une
polémique
je souhaite bien évidemment apporter de
la sécurité à l'ensemble des populations
du territoire de belfort l'avenue unité
mobile a permis de vacciner des
personnes à moins de 5 km de chez lg
permis aux auxiliaires de vie
d'accompagner les personnes
bénéficiaires des services des
auxiliaires de vie de se rendre et
comment à l'unité mobile et c'est le
conseil départemental qui prenait en
charge la totalité de leurs deux
prestations
je voudrais juste pendant qu on est
toujours dans le dossier social parler
d'une chose vous avez eu un ehpad qui a
connu une énorme crise et la
rosemontoise alors monsieur mais ça ne
prendra pas part à ces discussions parce
que c'est lui même qui est médecin à
l'intérieur de cet ehpad
vous envisagez maintenant de construire
peut-être un autre et pattes sur le
département
écoutez effectivement il ya tout juste
quelques beaux coups mais la tendance on
vit c'est cet épisode malheureux sur le
plan humain de la rosemontoise le 3
avril 2020 je décidé de la mise sous
tutelle de cet établissement avec une
administration provisoire conjointement
avec eux l' agence régionale de la santé
à l'époque ont déploré 18 essais et puis
là toute la moitié du personnel qui
était en arrêt c'était un véritable
drame qui se produisait et aujourd'hui
est en rentrer en contentieux avec
l'association qui gérait autrefois cet
établissement
il nous semble de plus en plus pertinent
d'envisager la construction d'un nouvel
ehpad de manière à ce que les pâtes
départementale alors on le confond n'en
confierait la gestion on n'a pas
vocation plus administrer un ehpad
mais sur un terrain qui appartient au
conseil départemental j'envisage
l'installation tas d pad 9 en plus la
réhabilitation du site fortement
onéreuse donc autant envisager du sang
pour sang neuf
on va faire le vide antique de ce qu'on
a fait le site de chênois notre unique
site public
oui alors nous on a une solution
alternative à ça c'est au lieu de
construire des ehpad pourquoi ne pas
envisager de laisser les personnes âgées
à domicile la c4
de l'essai alors il ya certaines
personnes qui ne peuvent pas rester chez
elle toute seule on est bien d'accord
mais au lieu de construire des ehpad
on peut trouver peut-être une solution
alternative moins chère et ça rendra
peut-être nos aînés je n'ai plus
tranquille en restant chez eux
samia jaber pour en compte la
construction d'un nouvel ehpad la
question ne se pose pas comme ça je
pense que là l'épidémie a montré les
failles de notre système
d'accompagnement des personnes âgées
notamment dans les structures ya eu
beaucoup trop de morts et je crois qu'on
n'a pas fini encore d'en parler je sais
pas s'il faut un nouvel ehpad
je pense qu'on a assez de place par
contre ce qu'il faut ce sont de
nouvelles politiques publiques pour
permettre aux personnes âgées d'avoir
une fin de vie les plus acceptables et
moi je suis plutôt en faveur de
nouvelles politiques publiques qui
permettent de maintenir à domicile ou
faire du logement par exemple dans notre
proposition de programme nous
proposerons deux montées en deux montées
en place un système qui permet aux
personnes âgées qui le souhaitent de
rompre l'isolément de ne pas être
isolées chez elles de faire de la
colocation est de mutualiser les aides à
domicile qui leur permettra aussi de
faire des économies
je pense que nous sommes attendus aussi
sur l'innovation et sur les nouveaux les
nouveaux accompagnement à créer je suis
pas sûr qu'il faille à nouvel ehpad en
réalité j'aimerais que l'on parle
maintenant de l'attractivité de ce
département du territoire de belfort qui
a une image donc industrielle est un peu
dur pour améliorer l'attractivité de ce
département que proposez vous mais moi
je pense qu'un taux de perte
d'attractivité je pense et oman sécurité
lorsque je pense mais vous êtes au
rassemblement national mais bien sûr je
pense pourquoi je pense sécurité parce
que je pense que justement ce qui a trak
tiff c'est la vie calme paisible et
l'homme en harmonie avec son
environnement voyez donc on peut parler
pas limite pour tourisme étaient rangés
pas de souci avec ça mais on parle
vraiment des gens qui habitent qui
vivent le territoire et qui veulent
vivre dans la sécurité
et c'est à vous c'est le premier droit
et je pense que là et c'est ça qui
attractif
vous savez des zones qui ne sont pas
attractifs si là où il ya de
l'insécurité
vous allez justement déménager dans
trois endroits où vous
et de la sécurité ça c'est attractif
voyez donc là après on peut décliner
s'il y a des actions affaire va faire
tourner un petit peu la rolls
attractivité monsieur messin vous
répondez quoi pour le département
quelles sont les idées que vous auriez
pour rendre le territoire plus attractif
donc l'attractivité je constate tout de
suite aux industriels pour leur
faciliter l'implantation ça sera ma zone
justement non c'est pas possible aux
industriels comme mc phee par exemple
alors mcphee c'est une entreprise qui
travaille dans l'hydrogène ou là c'est
ça qui travaillent dans l'hydrogène
c'est une entreprise de la drôme et puis
de l'isère qu'implanter sur plusieurs
sites en allemagne en valeur en italie
et cette implantation s'est fait par
grâce à la majorité présidentielle
donc c'est l'équipe de macron qui a pu
permettre cette implantation donc macro
on peut contester mais il apporte
beaucoup plus d'emplois qu'amazon c'est
très important puisque pas un emploi
industriel c'est plus deux emplois par
ailleurs donc si vous multipliez par 2
400 employés plus puissant vous êtes
avait 200 employés c'est ce que matt
fiddes devrait créer comme emploi voilà
à terme il n'y a jamais eu pour
l'attractivité c'est aussi je pense
beaucoup au tourisme le tourisme n'est
pas suffisamment développée on a un
territoire singulièrement bien pourvue
en tout cas le le massif vosgien n'est
pas encore assez bien développé et il ya
vraiment beaucoup de choses à faire pour
faire un pass touristique etc
il ya mis la maison de l'environnement
qui serait un re définir dans ses
fonctions samia jaber attractivité bon
je pense que notre département n'a pas
fini justement de montrer qu'il est un
territoire attractif
on a vécu jusque là sur des grandes
industries et nous avons une carte à
jouer
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas d'identité je pense qu'il
faut d'urgence créé cette identité d'un
territoire industriel avec de
formidables compétences avec une
université avec des laboratoires de
recherche je pense que la question
d'hydrogène et un âne un des éléments de
notre future identité
il faut évidemment
la construire le plus rapidement
possible pour sortir notre épingle du
jeu et commencer à compter que belfort
compte à l'échelle européenne
je pense que là nous avons de
formidables atouts au niveau de
l'énergie entre le transport l'énergie
nous avons tout pour réussir sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas fait grand
chose depuis six ans florian bouquet la
parole est à la défense
tout simplement changer l'image rappeler
comme on attire de nombreuses
entreprises
on voit bien la zone de l'aéroparc de
fontaine aujourd'hui elle est pleine
parce qu'on a encore une grosse annonce
à faire mais j'avais une santé il faut
semer tous les jours et puis ensuite on
récolte les fruits
on a annoncé amazon récemment et on
annonce et makfi encore plus récemment
il ya encore une autre annonce dans les
prochains c'est grâce au salon de levier
c'est surtout mon fils aussi à à
l'action conjointe de grands belfort
sodeb conseil départemental et cette
symbiose qui existe pour aller vendre le
territoire après sur termes
d'attractivité il ya bien sûr le
tourisme c'est pas pour rien que la
citadelle de belfort et le lions ont été
élues monument préféré des français en
2020 sa formidable atout dans le
territoire de belfort c'est sous une
mini france on trouve de tout de la
forêt de l'eau des pistes cyclables on
trouve de l'activité pêche l'activité
vélo est liée à la montée historique du
tour de france au ballon d'alsace la
planche des belles filles pas loin eh
bien écoutez entre malsaucy et le ballon
d'alsace ont un véritable terrain de jeu
pour les belfortains à travailler l art
permet des activités toutes saisons il
reste moins de dix minutes dans cette
émission alors avant de passer à la
conclusion je vous ai promis 30 secondes
à chacun d'entre vous je voudrais quand
vous posez aux injustes une petite
question politique sur laquelle je vous
demanderai des réponses courtes
christophe soustelle donc le
rassemblement national est en difficulté
au niveau régional et dans votre
département
julien odoul la tête de liste pour les
régionales est en pleine polémique en
pleine tourmente
vous avez dû changer de tête de liste
pour les élections régionales dans le
territoire est-ce que vous pensez que ça
aura un impact sur les élections
départementales du fait en plus que vous
nous présentez que deux
vous présenter des candidats comptent
que deux cantons sur n'a fait non je
pense pas je pense que ces polémiques
vont glisser comme l'eau sur le les
plumes d'un canard et furiani paraîtra
je pense que je pense d'abord quand on
regarde effectivement on a eu en a eu du
mal à monter des listes sur le
territoire de belfort mais c'est parce
que nous avons souvent des gens qui ne
veulent pas se montrer c'est
effectivement c'est très difficile c'est
ça sinon les eaux nous avons des scores
très très important et je pense que
julien oudoul va gagner la région
monsieur message comme je le rappelle un
vous êtes du modem le modem appartient à
la majorité présidentielle
or le modem quelquefois dans les
départements il est avec la majorité de
droite
quelquefois à la majorité de gauche vous
habitez ou en fait on est centriste et
en aide pour le bon sens
on est là où les querelles de clocher
des chapelles n'ont pas lieu
on est pour l'attractivité on est pour
la prospérité économique le bien qu'on
aime et centristes ça ne veut pas dire
opportuniste un coup je penche d'un côté
un coup je penche de l'autre en fonction
des circonstances
alors le port tunis mme honnêtement
c'est pour être élu et tant qu'il y aura
des élections il y aura des
opportunistes et si vous voulez votre
voix si vous voulez que votre discours
passe
vous êtes obligés de passer par là c'est
une obligation
moi je propose mon bon sens je propose
un espace démocratique et je propose
qu'on se réunisse pour collégialement
trouver des bonnes réponses alors j'ai
posé la question à monsieur messin où
habitez-vous je vous pose la même
vous vous êtes une ancienne du mdc le
mouvement de chevènement vous êtes une
ancienne ancien du ps
maintenant je vous ai divers gauche
politiquement vous habitez vous j'habite
là où j'ai toujours habité je suis une
élue de gauche une militante de gauche
ma famille est à gauche et aujourd'hui
je suis soutenu par l'ensemble des
partis que l'on connaît qui sont
aujourd'hui à gauche de la france a
soumis jusqu'au parti socialiste c'est
une
c'est historique dans le département du
territoire de cobham à l'inter ce délai
finalement vous vous battiez entre vous
déjà mais oui manger j'ai toujours été
sur la ligne montebourg donc j'étais pas
sur la ligne de monsieur hollande et de
la ligne de monsieur valls et ça n'est
un secret pour personne et c'est aussi
pour ça que j'ai quitté le parti
socialiste mais aujourd'hui mail
aujourd'hui le ce que l'on peut
constater c'est que nous avons réussi à
faire le rassemblement et nous avons un
soutien de l'ensemble des partis de
gauche c'est une première c'est
historique
un seul candidat présenté que dans les
contes ont obtenu que tous les leviers
sont à droite vous étiez comme dont nous
avons pris nos responsabilités et nous
avons été au rendez vous alors florian
vos bouquets yanbu car se présente donc
idéal bout car c'est le député les
républicains du territoire il se
présente sur un canton de belfort
il a déjà été condamné pour de faux
tracts lors des législatives de 2010 est
il doit passer en jugement le 1er
juillet justement parce que le procureur
a demandé son inéligibilité
est ce que vous craignez cette
inéligibilité non yann boucard est un
homme qui a de nombreuses qualités je
crois ça non et ça n'entache absolument
pas sa candidature parce qu'il était
condamné pour détournement de suffrages
électoraux par manoeuvres frauduleuses
le 17 juin 2020 c'est l' élection serge
où elle a été brillamment réélu avec
plus de 2000 voix d' avance donc il à
l'élection ayant été annulé eh bien on
peut considérer qu'il a déjà été
sanctionné pour cette situation si il
est déclaré inéligible
alors qu'il est dans votre majorité à ce
moment-là d'aviser mais de toute façon
il ya le bouquin est un homme formidable
sur qui je peux compter pour porter les
grands dossiers du terrain vous allez
des russes à l'essentiel vous allez me
dire aussi que damien meslot donc est un
homme formidable parce que dans tous ses
assistants parlementaires occupe
maintenant des postes clés dans le
département vous vous un député un
sénateur et lui à belfort et à au grand
baie belfort c'est pas un peu
hégémoniques tous à damien meslot je
veux lui rendre hommage parce que dès
lors qu'ils détectent des personnes qui
sont qui a qui aiment leur territoire
qui a envie de s'engager qui aime les
gens et bien
il leur confie des responsabilités et ça
c'est très fort bonjour en réalité
aujourd'hui moi je joue aujourd'hui
dirigea vers je ne vous ai jamais
interrompu à peu de courtoisie s'il vous
plaît damien meslot fait confiance à la
jeunesse et il leur confie des
responsabilités et il a bien raison
parce que les anciens moi je vois bien
aujourd'hui la gauche est incapable de
présenter des candidats dans tous les
cantons
et ça c'est grave parce qu'ils n'ont pas
su en confiance à la jeunesse on va
passer à la conclusion puisqu'il reste à
peine plus de trois minutes vous avez
trente secondes c'est vous qui avez
commencé c'est vous qui commencez la
conclusion vous avez la parole gardella
alors secondes pas plus à le en 2015
j'avais pris l'engagement de d'améliorer
la situation générale du département
bien je peux dire aujourd'hui aux
téléspectateurs que l'engagement il est
tenu les élus de la majorité
départementale ont tenu cet engagement
et ça je m'en réjouis on a travaillé
chaque jour avec intégrité et
transparence honnêteté avec ardeur et
avec la volonté de servir nos
administrés et bien c'est dans le même
esprit que je souhaite que le 20 juin
retrouvez nez lui une équipe
nouvellement élus des élus de la
majorité départementale pour trahison
même esprit et poursuivre l'action accor
initiés monsieur soustelle 30 secondes
pour vous également
oui bien donc donc je demande en faire
les électeurs à voter pour leur
assemblée nationale parce que ce sera
evry fut une vraie force d'opposition
aujourd'hui pourquoi l air est si haut
pourquoi il a justement tous les postes
et parce que nous sommes absents eh bien
je dis aux électeurs à aller voter allez
voter pour les deux listes qui se
présentent pour le rassemblement
national et vous verrez que vous aurez
la possibilité de vous faire entendre au
département et plus tard à la région et
pourquoi pas effectivement à la
présidence jean christophe mais ça pour
le modem alors dimanche 20 juin ça votre
avenir qui est en jeu
en 2021 lens reçoit politique n'est plus
de mise
soyons clair une même couleur
politique dans le territoire de belfort
s'est pas de débat pas de transparence
il faut que cela change ayez le courage
d'agir
mobilisez vous allez voter pour les
candidats de la majorité présidentielle
merci samia jaber c'est à vous que
revient donc le mot de la fin
eh bien j'ai envie de dire aux électeurs
que le changement de majorité à gauche
est possible
la gauche aujourd'hui présente sur trois
cantons giromagny grandvillars et
belfort 1 et nous faut gagner deux
cantons pour faire basculer la majorité
du département
l'équipe rassemblée et présente le
projet est plutôt ambitieux est solide
et je pense que nous seuls pouvons
répondre à la question environnementale
à la question de l'attractivité à la
question de l'accompagnement et de la
santé et donc j'appelle évidemment eux
l'ensemble des électeurs et notamment
aux électeurs de gauche parce que notre
seul handicap aujourd'hui nous à gauche
c'est l'abstention du peuple de gauche
et je pense que ce qui va se jouer le 20
et le 27 c'est le quotidien des familles
que ce soit des collégiens des personnes
âgées ou de l'enfance donc prenez part à
ce scrutin vous avez un billet vous vous
avez un peu débordé c'est bien ce que je
craignais fil des jours
donc je vous remercie madame et
messieurs d'avoir participé à ce débat
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je vous donne rendez-vous moi même donc
pour la semaine prochaine même endroit
même heure sur france 3 avec la deuxième
soirée consacrée donc au débat pour les
élections départementales et ce sera le
tour du doubs et du jura
merci de votre attention bonne fin de
journée bonne fin de soirée à bientôt
parfois
[Musique]